c'est jalouse comme une fille
vachement
je sais pas si tu trouves ton mec en
train de se faire
[Musique]
c'est dur comme question ça se passe
d'un accord commun ce genre de choses
on décide aujourd'hui que c'est terminé
non je sais pas je me renseigne je sais
pas
ment
ah bon je sais pas si tu trouves ton mec
en train de se faire
draguer par une pépée par exemple tu es
capable d'acheter des yeux
mannequin génial c'est vrai de ta vie
ressemble à Robin des Bois
tu es capable de craquer ou non comme
tout le monde est capable d'être traqué
quand quelqu'un
j'avais 15 ans que c'est hier soir ça
m'arrive fréquemment
non ça je sais plus je sais plus tu as
entendu parler
est-ce que tu préfères ton père ou ta
mère
c'est pas possible
j'ai eu les skis ou à Pinochet
[Musique]
le pouvoir à des gens dangereux quelque
chose de terrifiant en règle générale tu
penses qu'ils sont aussi pires l'un que
l'autre aussi
maintenant si tu devais partir sur une
île déserte tu préférais partir avec
Jospin ou Juppé
[Musique]
[Rires]
est-ce que tu préférerais être fusil ou
guillotiné
ça aussi c'est très con comme question
la chaise électrique n'entre pas avoir
de compte non
pas terrible c'est pas pareil là on est
en position comme ça
est-ce que imaginons toujours
si on disait voilà vous restez paralysé
toute votre vie allongée sur un lit en
fer en faire mais il y aura plus jamais
d'inondation au Bangladesh tous les
petits enfants du Bangladesh pourront
manger du riz à leur fin jusqu'à la fin
des temps
oui non je crois pas que j'irai jusqu'à
une sacrifier
ce serait idéalement je ferai mais en
pratique non je crois pas
dernière question maintenant parce que
de toute façon la bombe arrive
que voilà un jour tu allumes la radio un
matin tu te réveilles tu aimes la radio
atomique est partie de quelque part dans
une fusée et puis la bombe arrive dans 5
minutes qu'est-ce que tu fais quels sont
les dernières choses que tu fais enfin
tu appelles ta mère t'appelle ton père
tu t'envoies en l'air qu'est-ce que tu
fais
je crois que la dernière solution sera
la meilleure
pour être sûr de ne rien rater
vous et mettez un pouce bleu